[Music]
so uh
the trial is continuing
the alex jones trial is continuing and
uh there were uh
this is owen troyer testifying
let's see how aggressive they are
we're changing the world now it's time
to change our box with z
forwardslife.com
so right after you called neil hesslin a
liar
played a commercial to just tell z force
z shield you've got to have a lisa
objection cprc
411
[Applause]
let's see yeah okay
we have a running objection
correct watch so they're going through
because you don't think you called jill
hussein a liar right i didn't right
after you ran that piece and we'll get
to that part right now look at this
let's look at this
you ran that piece
you're in a commercial trying to sell
toxic metal and chemical defense support
right
i didn't run that that was probably
pre-programmed into our commercial
system free speech systems right after
they had you say the things that you
said about neil heslin right after that
they ran a commercial for a product that
they sell on their website called z
shield right
so what so
and
i'm sorry i'm sorry no yeah you're right
here you're right you know what the
media doesn't do that is brought to you
by pfizer cbs healthwatch sponsored by
fun so they're allowed to do it
the difference is the stuff that alex
jones says not gonna [ __ ] kill you
here's the thing
alex jones
did
exactly
basic basically what he did was he said
all right i'm going to copy
the exact same business model and put
the exact same amount of effort and work
into building
a [ __ ] brand that people watch and
i'm also gonna make a [ __ ] ton of money
off my own brand
same thing you guys do alex just copied
their
complete playbook he plays the same game
they play he just happens to say based
[ __ ] that they don't like and
honestly if you noticed this still to
this day is all about trump
because they never
gave a [ __ ] about alex jones or the
saint sandy hook [ __ ] they didn't even
give a [ __ ] about all that no because
that was that was they they brought it
up later because they wanted them off of
twitter this was trump this was when he
backed trump
and they saw that he had a
massive following yeah because before he
was just a crazy conspiracy guy and he's
like let him leave him alone let him in
richard linklater films and like he was
kind of a [ __ ] even lefties in austin
were kind of cool with them yeah yeah
man they do put chemicals in our water
bro monsanto bro chemtrails yeah yeah
and then like but then
trump came
and they ju he just backed trump and
they went all right well you know what
we can't have him
backing the guys we don't like because
he's always gonna back the guys we don't
like bottom line but he's but but now
they're like breaking down his business
like uh model and you're like royce said
it's like just so you mean just like you
guys do
that's what everybody does spread panic
follow it up with a commercial for
you know yeah a drug that fixes the
thing
yeah
you mean like every single report you
did about covet and then you say it was
bro then you would run a commercial by
pfizer what's the difference
it's called vertical integration
[ __ ]
and if you don't like it
if you don't like it then you stop doing
it yes
maybe you should next time you want to
do something maybe you should ask
yourself
is this good for the company thank you
thank you
that's a more
low-key [ __ ] office space very good
people don't usually use because info
wars
is actually an infomercial right
again
sir
then the local news is an infomercial
right which is and if infowars isn't
infomercial then doesn't your entire
thing fall apart
then okay then he's only for
entertainment and who cares what he says
he's allowed to say whatever he wants
and that's the problem and the problem
is there's a lot of people i clip the
last one thing
some people most people you know get
where we're coming from but there's some
people that are like
blinded by anger and what i mean is
they're upset because kids were killed
and they're upset that these parents had
to suffer more because of alex jones and
you could think that you're allowed to
think that
but the problem is is that you can't use
it as a justification to take somebody's
freedom of speech away and that's where
you have a problem
the whole point of freedom of speech is
to protect the exact thing that alex
jones did
yeah and as somebody who was in a civil
case and who got raped by a summary
judgment by a luck uh judge four years
into it instead of just letting it go to
the jury trial which is it was going to
that's a [ __ ] i'm very much against
them doing that because it just makes it
look right you should have just let them
figure it out
and
aside from all of that because they knew
a whole true jury was not going to find
him guilty so
uh and then the other issue is basically
like this this judge this judge is
running wild on them they're running
wild on them
and it's also the amount of money
because it's like they're making up like
a childishly like made-up number 150
million but that's you know what i mean
it's like hey all right so you defamed
these people and said some things about
them we're awarding you 100 gajillion
bajillion dollars
and you're like that's not even you
can't
quant you can't quantify that yeah no no
it's it's funny because
this is their way of going you're ruined
exactly and somebody in the chat right
on target brought up he goes and
infowars is more like an infomercial he
just goes mr lawyer if you want to go do
stand-up why don't you go bomb at the
austin open mic like [ __ ] you he's
trying to do a catchphrase that's what
this [ __ ] you want a little sound
bite
you want to be soundbite lawyer yeah
maybe you should have [ __ ] combed
your hair before you went for the sound
bite this this freeze frame he looks
like the vulture from looney tunes the
[ __ ]
[Music]
uh yeah this is infowars more like an
infomercial
also i'll be appearing on channel 7 news
brought to you by dan newland attorneys
of law
later tonight i'll be their legal expert
yeah exactly
also by the way i have to bring it up
whenever it's on camera [ __ ] law and
crime
yeah [ __ ] hey [ __ ] you lawn crime
sorry [ __ ] with our boyfriend
get some
go get some [ __ ] public dell they do
is air [ __ ] stuff that's publicly
available and then they're trying to
copy straight and they pop people
yeah tmz tried that with uh when i
played the jeff hardy stuff on nightwave
and i was like i literally just wrote i
wrote the the dui video yeah i think i
played that video on dave and i didn't
get any [ __ ] that's weird well i think
at first they were trying to oh okay i
played it
very early on when it happened and that
night they were like oh you just got a
copyright claimed by tmz and i wrote
that appeal right i'm like duh [ __ ] i
did volusia county florida [ __ ] they
put that [ __ ] up on their own youtube
yeah that's true and that's public
domain so and i didn't even play it off
tmz i played it off i was like i played
that off volusia god damn
you know tmz you're right tmz does that
a lot right remember the other day when
i was playing that trailer and you're
like you have 80d why'd you stop playing
the trailer you know what happened to me
today when i was playing a trailer
boom in the middle of it this is copied
it was it was
joke by the way but for those that were
looking for today's day wave you're
gonna have to wait another hour because
i had to trim stuff out because joe coy
is one of the most egregious [ __ ] you
i was making fun of him because he's
dating chelsea handler now but um
he
anything any video of him on the
internet you can't even play a second of
it like it's
pop pop pop pop and i'm like all right
man [ __ ] you and also he's a shitty
comic on top of all that
uh jokoy is that vegan yeah i swear to
god
i mean it's not like pablo francisco
which i showed you before the show
i showed immersed the infamous pablo
francisco dude what was that about yeah
did adam lepakowski kiss says esther coo
mentioned us on trash tuesdays i don't
know that's true or not he's yelling at
all caps repeatedly i i don't even care
to check it right now i just wanted to
say it and acknowledge you so you stop
yelling in all caps on the chat yeah
send me a link i mean what do you want
check it out after the show yeah
i want to look at the source can you put
a px20 which is in evidence
oh i do px 20 sometimes it's a little
tough though since p90 it's hard to do
every day you know you're thinking of
p90x
if it's useful to you
have uh oh a px20 yeah i was gonna get
one of those but you know the charging
stations and the lines are always like
[ __ ] around the plaque
anyway we don't have to really play more
than that i i just wanna mess with our
boy yeah i know seriously stop messing
dude i love that by the way people have
asked me about this
um because i ran into some people i knew
this weekend who know about the watch
the show it's one of my one of my old
gun guys that does like my ffls and
stuff but he doesn't work there anymore
i ran into him and like a couple other
people i knew and um he was asking me
about this and he was like what do you
think about this trial and blah blah and
i was like look man
i'll be the first to say i am the most
biased person on the planet
so
i'm absolutely honored he shows his side
i'm like because he's nice to us
he's nice to us at the end of the day
you know what do you want